[Music]
you've got a secret sewer exit built
into your shop
yeah
i
okay
cool yes
if you see any bodies down here pretend
you didn't
why would we
talk about something we definitely won't
see got it
[ __ ] oh
good friend of mine
shut up [ __ ]
decent friend
do you want to die
acquaintance
you're heading into a battalion of
tedious troops how do you know that ah
i snuck a tracker into your clothes in
case i ever needed to kill you stay
quiet
sneak
don't run
pretend you're on a stealth mission huh
and that you're not an idiot and if they
catch you make sure you die before you
give me up okay
stealth like shooting them quietly
like not shooting at all oh
okay
i guess
tdr troops ahead gotta be sneaky what
how i'm not a covert operative just stay
low and follow my lead well just you
know stay quiet and avoid them all
hold up i love you but i would never put
the words quiet and octavio in the same
solar system as each other you got a
better idea
soldier can't scream with a crushed
windpipe
wait so our options are to sneak around
and pray nobody swats us or
quietly murder everyone we come across
so uh yeah
whenever you're ready
let's uh maybe try not to murder people
prude
all right then
follow my name
what's that
it's okay
all clear
[Music]
wherever they're going we'd better
follow
oh crap won't be able to cross the room
without him seeing us
you can't like zoom up to him and knock
him out chair gets loud if i move too
fast everyone in the sewers will hear us
it's okay
i got an idea
i like the kid but i gotta say your
brother has problems octavio what are
you doing as long as i move only when
he's not looking he'll think i'm just a
harmless little ammo box
then when i get close i'll distract him
and we get passed it's street wise i'm
street wise
i never should have left you alone down
here here we go
so weird
guy in a box
no
wait wait
just let me
uh
i'm not who you're looking for
i disagree
is is that up
no
it couldn't be
not worth much in the market but to a
true vollander
connoisseur my vault lander
you want it it's yours just let me go
i'm not gonna take it
vault landers must be earned
to the right of glorious combat
want to
fight
indeed i do
will versus will
vault lander to votelander
oh
okay
beat me
and i'll let you pass without incident
as is the warriors
but if i win
your vault lander
and your life are for it
what is he doing let's just grab him
no
it isn't up to us anymore octavio must
find glory in the truth of the figures
only through plastic combat will our
fates
be decided why are you people like this
ready
ready
come back
select your outlander
amara
amara versus
zane
baldlanders
fight
r i
you won
i respect your superior combat skills
leave this place
i must gather my thoughts
okay we're uh gonna go this way
no more words
i said go
where
is it
i don't know
how many places can you hide the
entrance to a vault yeah
should be conspicuous
right
or are they
i mean this could be the vault entrance
right here
try it
come on do it do it do it
cram it in there
negative
not the volt entrance
well
it's worth a shot
three tedious soldiers of questionable
intelligence stand between us and the
vault
fran can you take them
is froggert better than ice cream
hold on are we sure about this
faults tend to be guarded by big angry
alien things if one shows up do you want
to be the one holding the balt key
if i'm not cracking skulls what do you
propose we do there's some cover down
there we could try to i don't know get
closer
we'll have to be extremely quiet
yeah it's a stealth mission
[Music]
sorry
all this sneaking better lead up to some
violence
it will
probably
just follow me and make sure they don't
see you
now
let's go
yes
this looks like an opening confirmed
that's an opening
opening confirmed you got the key you go
first oh no no no after you oh i
couldn't possibly oh no no
seriously i said
i see something
wait wait hold on a second
i think i've done it yes it's
opening yeah
doug
doug no wait isn't it anthony anthony
doug anthony
it is now
or never
let's go let's go
wait
going for backup
[Music]
it's okay no big deal just a couple of
alien warriors pretty sure they didn't
see us
time to boogie kids friend's gonna get
us out of here
[Applause]
thank you fran
no sweat everyone okay
all good
perfection
i'm sorry octavio
we can figure this out they're just
aliens
more like robots
the iridians apparently had them built
to guard the vault before they pissed
off to whatever dimension they're
probably hiding in
what
i read
the point is we are done we'll be lucky
just to find a way out of here with our
lives
whatever's in that vault it's not worth
our lives might be worth octavio's
i know this is stupid
i know but this
you know how long i've spent trying to
put something
anything together
i've been waiting for a chance like this
and if i don't take it
there might not be another you might get
killed i was dying slow before you got
here
at least getting killed by a space guard
would be a step up
you're such an idiot i told you i know
that
well
i came here to help so
tell me how to help
wait
i got it
what's good doc
paco i need juniper what you're ratch
dummy can't you find me down here should
you get a musk then do it
what the hell you up to raches they're
tunnelers they know every route into
we're out of a place
if there's a path that gets us into that
vault without exposing ourselves paco's
pet rash juniper will know about it
good idea right fran
yes
foreign
oh
that animal has zero right to be as cute
as it is
i would follow her to hell and back how
about to a vault
i don't do raj
[Music]
who's a good girl who's a good girl
juniper is universal good girl
well
who wouldn't be a good girl for that
kind of attention
i
wouldn't
would
not
i'm uncomfortable
all right girl we're counting on you how
do we get to the vault from here
[Music]
oh
it's all right
i'll find my own way through
you sure i'm pretty sure this is the
only path
i'm not convinced those guardians aren't
trying to break through and murder us
all so
i'll buy you two time
fran i don't think you do actually way
too much
you kids get going now i mean it friend
i i said go
right
we'll see you on the other side
we made it
it's
beautiful friends should be seeing this
she could name a frog after it
like
praline portal punch or
top secret
secret sauce
you're right
friends should be here
friend
oh
miss me
no
anyway look
all that effort and juniper just led us
to the other side of this
glowy arch thingy
it's quite clever actually it's a
dimensional photo so you can enter and
exit it from either side and on this
side the guardians can't see us so we
have all the cover we need to do you
want to explain more about vault physics
or can we go inside it now
[Music]
[Music]
you